this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday the 17th of
October UFC 280 is here get closer to
the octagon with DraftKings Sportsbook
and official sports betting partner of
the UFC right now today any new
customers just bet five dollars on any
of the fight card and get 203 bets when
your fighter wins it's perfect to get
your bankroll up for the end for the
playoffs the baseball world series and
the rest of the NFL and everyone can
boost their weddings with drafting same
game ballets right now I'm looking at
the winner of the beta Yen sugar fight I
love bdn on this what a boost your
winning this place a UFC 280 same game
parlay today the more legs you add the
more money you win how long will the
fight be will we get disqualified
knockout decision download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app now today
use promo code Joey and throw down five
beans on UFC 280 get 203 bets when you
fight a wins that's code Joey this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official Sports Betty partner of the UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details listen
and then Sunday you can take your
winnings and move on to the NFL
DraftKings download the app now and go
win some [__] money the joint
is also brought to you by
heart and soil as you know I've been
trying to eat healthy for the last few
years I do my best it's why I've been
taking beef organ supplements from heart
and soul I started my little
supplementation about three weeks ago
and I feel a lot [__] better my
recuper my recovery is better beef
organs are the most nutrient dense foods
on the planet more than kale spinach and
blueberries that's why they called
Nature's multivitamin listen
heart and soul makes me feel [__] my
back you started after jiu jitsu now I
can lift weights the next day in the old
days people ate organs for thousands of
years and never suffered from obese
through the heart disease and
anti-immune issues or infertility
because they were eating organs Nations
Nature's Most treasured Foods founded by
Dr Paul saladino heart and soul
supplements are made from grass-fed
Finnish beef organs feel like a man when
you take supplements made from liver
heart kidney spleen and tacticals you'll
be living like [__] Silence of the
Lambs hot and soil can help you reclaim
their Birthright the radical Health go
to heart and soul that cold
CEO heart and soil dot Co use code Joey
10 for 10 off your first order that's
heart and soil
s-o-i-l offer applies to one-time
purchases no subscription try them today
and feel like a [__] new Savage and
the joint is also brought to you by come
on CBD lion is back with a pop is back
with a whole new game you understand me
go to cbdline.com look at the fine line
of supplements they got CBD whether it's
gummies cream [__] eye drops Delta
eight gummies use my discount get 20 off
your first order go to cbdline.com
pressing code Joey let's get this party
started it's Monday [__]
mornings we ain't got time to play games
[Music]
foreign
what's happening You Beautiful
[__] it's Monday the 17th of
October we're moving right along
Christmas [__] is out at the stores you
know people threatening blizzards and
whatnot but it's a beautiful [__]
week it's mid [__] month and we're
ready to go one two three interesting
week last week Kanye went off the
[__] wagon whatever the [__]
medication they had that [__] on
he abandoned ship on that [__]
guys he's talking stuff about Jews
they're concerned the Jewish League
ripped out [__] the bank room out dog
when the bank throws you out
we got a [__] problem especially when
you got 165 million gazillion dollars in
that [__] do you understand me that
they told them you got to go for your
[__] comments and it's funny because
guys listen
Kanye West is a brilliant artist you
know and whatever he does danda and all
that [__]
and he's got a great story with the
broken jaw and everything but you know
man
you could tell about 10 years ago I
think he did a show in like Oakland
where he went off on the audience
and right there you knew there was a
problem listen guys when somebody has a
[__] great talent like just a great
talent
it's an aptitude for creativity
somewhere along the line they're gonna
lack stuff
somewhere whether it's social Grace
whether it's social cues it just makes
sense I'll give you 10 [__] people
that are brilliant geniuses
but they can't put it all together sting
is a brilliant [__] genius have you
ever seen him get interviewed you want
to hate yourself in the [__] head he
shows up with a ukulele and wants come
on sting just because your little
buddies at the vineyard told you that
was great don't take it the [__]
heart his genius though was so [__]
brilliant listen to those [__] early
police albums some of that [__] you
listen to and you're like this is sharp
[__] I saw the police like in 83 84. and
it was amazing I I was a fan of their
music but it was one of those bands
where
I liked a lot of the people I liked
Stuart Copeland I think the bass player
is a bad [__] I love sting but
something about sting just used to
bother me and then one day he showed his
true colors and he [__] uh you know
broke up to one of the girl it's a great
band you know number two
Roger Waters let's talk about that
[__] guy he's pulling a Kanye episode
right now Roger Waters they're doing the
same thing go to Roger waters's show
look at the albums he's put out there's
no arguing with nobody that that dude is
a [__] genius
that dude is a [__] genius but you
need a Tama it's like if I get Five Guys
from the Rucker League one of the best
basketball courts in the country in New
York style I don't know if it's still
there and I put him in the NBA they're
gonna go 50 50. they're wild they're
slam dunking they're stealing they're
popping but they're not playing
fundamental basketball so I got to put a
dude in there a white dude a five foot
ten white dude to slow it down a little
bit and let's think this [__] out no
disrespect to nobody watching but
[__] uh if that you know not to take
away Roger Waters says some crazy [__]
and he attacks crazy people in Israel
and the whole [__] deal
and you know you go watch the the show
you know when you walk in it's like [__]
Pink Floyd and all this stuff [__] Dave
Gilmore you know but listen the genius
is undeniable it's unfucking deniable
you know you guys see your Geniuses that
you like uh
the [__] dude from Apple
Gates whatever the [__] his name is Bill
Gates whatever the [__] he is Apple you
know me I'm not co-corporate America but
Bill Gates you can't he's got [__] 82
billion dollars but you could see he
looks like a half a [__] [__]
from time to time him and his wife sit
there like you know that's what happens
when you get you're such a genius that
you go [__] mad guys and that's
what's going on
with Kanye West and I'm not making
excuses from I never guys you never hear
me talking about Kanye but this is from
what I see I see this as he started this
[__] years ago then you go to Wyoming
and Dave Chappelle had to go talk him
off the cliff and Wyoming and all this
[__] his genius is unparalleled the
people around them have not when you
have somebody like that it's very you
know everybody always goes well why
don't we have people around them I said
listen that type of Genius that type of
attitude that type of bravado nobody's
going to tell you to tame it down
and when you look at that stuff you look
at it and go maybe he's saying that [__]
to just get attention
that's the other side of a complete
[__] genius Madonna used to be a
genius now I don't know what she's doing
you know the other day she came out her
[__] you're 60 years old you look like
a small [__] Japanese lady now I
don't know what pla I don't know where
she got her plastic surgery her [__]
Yoko Ono Surgery Clinic I don't know who
the [__] did the surgery on her but I'm
not taking nothing from her
when Madonna was cooking with gas she
was cooking with gas Madonna pulled one
of the great listen there's two people
who have pulled the great [__] wool
over your eyes
maybe three number one Britney Spears I
love what a deck that [__] could shake
but she can't say but millions of people
go to her shows Madonna Madonna's voice
went on the second [__] hour
you know I love him with the dog and I
love Madonna everybody I love all that
[__] there's some [__] Madonna [__]
that you've listened to now and you go
God damn Madonna in the 90s was on fire
deeper and deeper those jams were on
[__] fire with the black guy popping
the balloon the video [__] tremendous
I love that I love all that [__] but
that genius also becomes the handicap in
a way
you know they're just so [__] smart
like those dudes can't do an edible an
edible wouldn't do anything to Roger
Waters you give I'll give [__] Kanye
West 2 000 milligrams of ABX capsules
and that [__] will stand there
they don't do nothing to those people
that it's it's I've seen it I've seen it
so you know if you're Jewish I'm sorry
for his comments I'm sorry I'm even
giving this guy light you know how much
I love the juice but
give him a [__] break the pork and
then he's gone through the Kardashians
didn't they [__] make one guy turn
into a woman
something is [__] up there the the
[__] white kid he went off the deep
end the husband to the chubby chick
[__] him was puking with foam in his
mouth
the basketball player you know
there's some about that too so I'm about
that [__] devil house because that's
got to be the devil's house that's where
the devil goes to [__] summer
vacation is the Kardashians or something
these people they keep giving them money
and they keep wrecking these poor
[__] guys that dude kissing whatever
his [__] name is they used to be
married to the the cute sister because
there's the chubby one Kim and then
there's the older one that's dating the
tattoo now they're always swapping spit
her ex-husband he [__] went off the
deep end this guy is jumping up and down
on a yacht with a scarf on he got really
[__] [__] but that's enough about
[__] Kanye West and whatever I just
see it for what it is
I wouldn't pay if Tanya if Kanye West
attack Cubans or anybody else I
I wouldn't I take it with a [__]
grain of salt I woke up to something
that he was doing a podcast
talking about that
the dude
died from Fentanyl and the cops weren't
stepping on his neck
George Floyd
he's going off this morning about that's
what I woke up to like I I did what I
did I we had breakfast I came down I
took a shower I opened the computer and
there was a video right there front and
center of Kanye and I'm like
oh no he didn't
oh no he didn't oh yes he did he said
that this dude died of fentanyl that he
watched the documentary about George
Floyd I don't even know a documentary
existed I'm gonna have to go on Amazon
Prime tonight see what's cooking you
know what I'm saying and uh now it was
kind of disturbing but again I looked it
and go ah
that's just Kanye you know what I'm
saying like just I don't know what he's
gonna do I don't know what the this
week's gonna be interesting Monday
morning is going to be interesting I
have not checked to see what's going on
with him today but
it's mental health guys the pandemic
didn't hurt
that living in California with people
telling you you're [__] great it just
it either breaks you or it changes you
so badly that
I spoke to a friend of mine in
California
well-known actor hasn't worked really
in about six years still drives a Range
Rover
gave a podcast a shot and the other day
he called me to ask what was going on
you know have I been on any auditions
and he's my age you know he's 60 61.
but he was asking me you know what I
thought what's going on I told him I you
know I didn't want to tell him that I
met with De Niro when I the auditions I
had I told him I had a few additions I
didn't know I didn't want him to feel
bad you know
and you know that that little [__]
dream he's got a he's got a grandchild
he's got a son you know he's got so much
opportunity especially like with
podcasting he's a big Time Sports guy
he called the other day with going back
and forth and while I'm talking to him
he's telling me about you know and I'm
and I don't interfere guys I I I'd love
to but I can't
I give it a couple days I think about
how I should attack it and then I'm
gonna call him back this week
you know this guy has been getting beat
up for the last seven years I mean no he
can't and he's a sweetheart of a guy
never says boo
you know I just watched one of his
movies the other day you know he the the
movie business changed he was a TV guy
he was a big time TV guy and that was 20
years ago the show ended so he popped a
few movies here and there I met him on
like a simple pilot and then we clicked
and we became friends and now we've been
friends for 20 years you know I he never
came on the podcast nothing like that
uh
you know his kids are grown up he's in
La still fighting that life which I
admire the [__] out of anybody
he's got money put away you know he gets
a pension from sag
so the other day called and I could tell
he's down you know he's like nothing's
flying my way the auditions he's not
good with home auditions you know people
every Everything Has Changed guys
and when I got off the phone with him
like I felt bad but at the same time I
could help this dude how can I help him
like how can I help this dude
so for the last three days I've been
thinking about how I'm going to call
this dude and tell them listen man get
rid of the Range Rover
get rid of your wife's Mercedes or
whatever the [__] they drive
you know you got a gorgeous house it's
paid for you have equity in the home
what the [__] are you doing even Marky
Warburg left California
Markie Warburg resettled in in Vegas and
he's one of the biggest [__] stars on
the map you know California just doesn't
work for you and he's got kids it's time
for him to get that money
you could still Live Your Dream
the [__] out of there take that weight
off your shoulders just to [__] uh
just a game you're playing to keep up
appearances
takes work that wears on you you know
and unlike me I don't give a [__] about
the Joneses I don't give a [__] what
they think I gotta switch it with a
stain on it I don't give a [__] he's one
of those guys that goes to premieres and
you know he still works that angle and
it's like I'm the type of guy if I'm not
in that movie I'm not showing up to that
[__] Premiere what am I gonna go do
hi I came to support no you didn't you
came to get a free [__] meal don't
stop with the support everybody always
supports you came to see what you could
get out of this so with him he's trying
to you know PR himself back we discussed
the podcast 20 times he every time his
wife wanted him to do it this way you
know well I spoke to my wife your wife
is a [__] she makes sweaters for a
living what the [__] that no well she
was okay
so now he's in a rock and a hard place
you know no money's coming in you know
no money's coming in
he brokens his retirement two years ago
he collected his sack pension
and you know there's only one answer
and it's like listen
sell the [__] house
sell get rid of those cars like them on
fire like the Range Rover on Fire Light
the [__] Mercedes on fire and go get
yourself a 300 000 house in Tennessee
you could still put your auditions on
tape your dream is still alive
but for you to be out there still
banging out with these guys with white
hair it's getting old it's time for you
to take that money and go
have a great time with your wife I love
my daughter I [__] love my daughter
but if my daughter was 18 in college me
and my wife would be [__] hottie
every weekend I swear to God I would she
would get a job at Costco or some [__]
I'd get something going on I'd sell some
weed whatever the [__] I had to do and
on the weekends I just go to Red Bank
and hold hands
that's what old people do you know what
I'm saying that's what you do with your
wife you do simple [__] things
you stay active so you don't have to be
in the [__] doctor's office
and I have what happened to me was bro I
got a new
my whole you know like they have vaginal
rejuvenations and all that [__] I got a
[__] soul Rejuvenation when I moved
here I looked around I saw what I was
doing
I saw what everybody else was doing and
it just wasn't working for me I forgot I
I never forgot that who I was and where
I was in this situation so now I see
that it works for me and I see that it's
worked for other people
people who have gotten out like just
said you know what we're still going to
be comedians you're not going to stop
being a comic you're not going to stop
being an actor and you can write in a
[__] Closet in Moscow
think about it but if you're out I'm
trying to save this guy a hundred
thousand dollars a year and
stress
it's not worth it but it's not you know
it's just not worth it and I'm not
saying you're over what I'm saying is
that you could move to Tennessee
Michigan Texas wherever the [__] you
want and you could still work your magic
you could do a podcast you could do
Instagram video whatever the [__] you
want it's not necessary to be in that
rap race get stuck in traffic nobody
listen across the country since we've
had this pandemic nobody's seeing you
for auditions
I had went to an audition last week a
live one and I had to wear if I had to
take a covert test but here's the funny
thing when I was waiting to go upstairs
I was talking to the other actors in the
room and I brought to that attention
that hey guys we haven't been in an
in-person audition in three years and
they all looked at me they're like I
know we didn't know how to act it was
completely different like what I did
last week [__] I hadn't done it in three
goddamn years even to take an audition
for that debt where you have sides and
and it was way before that where I went
to an audition The Sopranos I got on a
tape because that's the business that
it's become but anyway I'm going to
congratulate Chris camozey for getting
this [__] knockout win he uh got like
a knockout he's one of the guests the
guy that used to send the fit soda great
product they gotta [__] knockout and
bed knuckles
and uh I want to talk to you guys about
something that I caught a lot of heat
over
and I'm happy the door opened again
because I made a statement and I got
[__] hate mail but I didn't give a
[__] because I stood behind my
statements
okay
when you shooting a movie you're
shooting a movie with there's 20 actors
and there's 40 key grips you know people
who work on the set when you shoot a TV
show
there's even more
okay
if Mike and I were talking about
residuals before and I showed him my
residuals on sag how you they get
printed every Sunday and it tells you
the date of when they're going to get
sent out and you expect to check like
three days after that but it also tells
you the amount that you're getting and
what you're getting it for
and I was telling Mike that if you look
at my uh checklist there's a check for
four cents that's coming tomorrow
there's a check for 36 Cents 464. there
was like seven checks coming not one
check over thirty dollars all the way
and trust me guys there's one check for
30 and the rest of them were like you
know three dollars
[__] like that then there's one check
for 150.
how weird is this business
I get you know from my 1997 1998 2003
like Mad TV's not playing but somebody's
putting in a DVD case and selling it so
they've sent me 18 cents and I'll get a
check for 18 cents now 20 years ago I
would take those 18 cents when I was
snorting coke and I go I'm doing back
you know I'm ripping this up because I
didn't have a bank account I would cash
my check out a check cashing place slash
liquor store so so write a
I [__] uh you know you don't you get
these little checks and stuff but this
these Productions I did with 15 years
ago so somebody's playing them China
Australia every once in a while you get
a red check you got a red envelope you
sag it's not on that sheet that comes in
and it's a red envelope and that means
it's International
so you're getting a check from Canada
you're getting a check from England
whatever and you open those like oh [__]
here's the [__] King Marion it's like
nine dollars you know so
but one of the checks for 159
is from a show called How I Met Your
Mother
that they hired me I was wrong for it
they hired me because I blew up the
audition and then when I got there I
wasn't right so they pretty much used me
as an extra
that show sends me a check
every 90 days for 159 dollars since
the beginning and I don't know how long
when I shot that I have no idea
it's got to be over 10 years ago yeah
got to be that thing spits out though I
got this [__] two men and a baby
what's that show uh you know with
Charlie Sheen and the other guy Two and
a Half Men I remember I'll never forget
getting the call for Two and a Half Men
they said listen Two and a Half Men
wants to hire you for the Christmas
special you gotta sing and all this [__]
and I'm like I don't know about singing
they go well this is what they're gonna
pay and I was like dog I spray some
Listerine in my [__] eyeballs right
now to get this [__] singing code
so if you watch this episode it's not
Charlie Sheen it's
uh Ashton Kutcher yeah Ashton kutch's
episode and uh
I have to I'm with the Two Italians
three other two other Italians up the
corner one of them got a bat we got a
sing whatever
it was brutal it was brutal three days
to shoot yeah yeah it's play play it all
the time
that [__] episode has given me so
much [__] cash over the year and I'm
not talking about forty thousand to
check like guys like 300 every time they
send a check so they send a check four
times a year that's 1200 bucks that's
gasoline money that's gasoline money you
know you're not gonna get I've told you
guys in this business you're not gonna
get rich off one thing but if you got 20
things going on and you add all those
things up you're still not gonna get
rich but it's not bad if you know when
you add 200 600 450 you know at the end
of the month you're like that's not a
bad [__] living I didn't make two
million but hey you know I'm shopping
I'm eating [__] clams everything is
good but my point being that I shot if
you go on my MDB I did 63 credits
63 TV you know and movies and that
doesn't count the short films and all
this [__] and you have sets guys and you
after the first day everybody's nice
second day everybody's night third
everybody starts showing their colors
and after four days people start telling
stories about this guy did you ever work
with Mike yeah I worked to my sweetheart
of a guy did you work with this guy did
you hear the story when I worked with
this guy holy [__] at lunch time he went
and shot heroin and he came back and
they couldn't shoot production
you hear that and you're like wow that's
crazy I'm talking about some crazy
[__] Cuban dude there was a show
called Kingpin and uh at lunch time he
went and shot everyone and then never
showed back up they fired him off the
show but you keep hearing these little
things you know you hear things about
Tom Cruise never negative you know I've
just heard a little though he works like
a dog and all that stuff you hear little
things about Cameron Diaz used to when
you work for Cameron Diaz on Friday you
rap and she takes everybody to a
location Miami Beach Washington DC you
know there's some cool [__] out
there Adam Sandler I've never heard a
bad story about that was around that
[__] for a year and that dude
was solid he got more solid every day
but you just you know and you have to
think what are people saying about me
you know oh he came on a set one time
and threatened the [__] director
he came on the set and stole all the
roller skates from basketball you know
there's a thousand little things like
that I never got into a fist fight or
nothing like that I never got [__]
blasted on the set or nothing like that
if not I wouldn't be working but there
were situations that were low end
and people probably just said you know
what he was having a bad I mean one time
I had an argument one of my best friends
on the set because he put me in a room
with no windows and I sat there [__]
reading reading a stupid book and the
claustrophobia got to me and I went on
the set and I had [__] anxiety but
anyway it don't matter I've always been
a gentleman I've always showed up in
time I did have a beef
with the producer from The Longest Yard
he made me go to the doctor to tell me
that I had to stop snorting coke and all
this [__] yeah tremendous so that you
have those stories but listen
the longest short stories even though
they were crazy
Peter Siegel hired me for Grudge Match
and he referred me for a different job
so it couldn't have been that crazy so
that's my point I never had a big issue
on a set like that but when you get on
such
you talk about different actors now I
did a movie called Analyze That with
dinero and uh
Anthony lumpoglia there were some cool
[__] on that set
and one of my all-time favorite Heroes
the guy who wrote stripes and all that
[__] I forget what his name is
and that's the first time I heard
something negative about
Murray Bill Murray yeah a couple months
ago he did something and I came on and I
told you how I felt about Bill Murray
and people were [__] pissed oh yeah
oh yeah people were making [__] up
comments on YouTube and all this [__]
and you know somebody has sent to me did
you say something about Bill Murray
[__] people listen man I spoke I
didn't speak from a personal experience
but I smoked I spoke from
20 different people
not two not three not four I can tell
you 20 sets I was on
that somebody said to me the dog I
worked with Bill Marion
somebody was telling me a story about
Saint Vincent the one he did with the
chubby chick and [__] the chubby chick
didn't like him I mean it was just it
just I just kept hearing this I never
even knew about the Lucy Lou I never
knew about the Seth Green I never knew
that he [__] threw Seth Green in the
garbage can I never even knew yeah that
came out last week I never knew that he
hated the staff the cyanide live that he
hated Adam Sandler he [__] hated
Chris Farley he was just [__] a prick
and they were like saying that you know
yeah they were saying you know what he's
very nice to his fans but he's a
douchebag the people on the set I was
never talking out of line I was never
talking online let's get something
straight one of my top 10 movies is
[__] Caddyshack one of my other
movies is [__] stripe I like them as
much as you guys but somewhere along the
line guys when I got into comedy I just
started hearing [__] the same way
the reason I don't like Cosby
I started hearing [__] about Cosby when
I got into comedy I just started hearing
little things when I saw him I had in
1995 there was the Colorado Comedy
Festival and Cosby performed in Colorado
Springs and I went down there as a
fanboy comedian open Miker to see what
all the fuss was about because I did
like one of the specials
I'll never forget this I walked in on
you know first of all I don't even know
who I was with I couldn't even tell you
but there was like a green room and then
there was like a big reception area it
was a comedy thing and somebody gave me
their pass I wasn't even nobody knew
where the [__] I was nobody talked to me
I was just yeah he's a comic leave him
alone he's [__] [__] stiff he did
some time whatever and I went through
this thing
and I'll never forget I got maybe 15
feet from Cosby
and he was complaining
he was complaining about some of these
sex jump
somebody in New York like Cosby was part
of something he had to come out and as
he was walking heard somebody say
something that wasn't uh you know it was
just off color and he complained about
him and then he went into a whole
diatribe with the producer of the plan
everybody else about dirty comedy and he
started bad mouthing Eddie Murphy
right there like this is why I don't
perform this is why I turned down Harlem
night just a bunch of stupid [__] he was
saying
and I was like God damn it
I wanted to like him
because he did a joke on one of his
specials that I thought was brilliant
about buck buck you know and I didn't
know anything about comedy I watched
Bill Cosby you know I used to watch Fat
Albert as a kid
I like Bill Cosby for about a week and
then I bumped into a man by the name of
Richard Pryor and Cosby could suck my
dick and then like I always heard he had
this beef with Eddie Murphy like he took
Eddie Murphy aside and you got to work
clean Eddie Murphy told him to suck his
dick but
I just heard shitty things about him I I
love to tell you that I heard that he
[__] roofied somebody and took him
back to the trailer and [__] game
pudding whatever I'd love to tell you
that I'd love to tell you that but I
never heard that I never really heard
that I didn't I didn't hear about that
until you people started hearing about
it I just heard about his and I still
remember in 87 when he [__] made the
chick uh
Lenny Kravitz's wife he may what's her
name Lisa Bonet he fired her because she
had a sex scene an Angel Heart nobody
remembered that nobody remembered that's
how much of a [__] hypocrite that
[__] was
and I just heard different things about
his attitude and I never really wanted
to work with him but Bill Murray was the
same guys I'm not here
making [__] up
I'm here [__] uh listening to what
people say to me and then somebody says
on the internet and we talk about it on
here
Hollywood's a big [__] place but it's
a small place guys
and you know everybody has a story
everybody saw something
I could tell you oh half of these things
that people say people saw but they
didn't want to lose their jobs
they didn't want to you know Gina Davis
came out against Bill Murray last week
now they're posting a video online about
Bill Murray on some talk show with Gina
Davis and he's doing creepy stuff today
he was getting attacked on [__]
Twitter or yesterday Sunday I was
watching something on Yahoo the Sport
lines and he was getting [__] slammed
on [__] uh
I don't know what he did now
listen and he and most of the people
saying what I say to you
over the years they treat these people
like you know they do nothing wrong
and when you're young and you're stupid
you listen to these [__] guys
I had great experiences with James
Coburn [__] I had great experiences
with [__] uh
Adam Sandler Chris Rock I had Tracy
Morgan was great to work with you know
you hear all these crazy people but I
tell you I had the hardest [__] sets
I had were people that you [__]
like
like that America thinks this you know
one guy's guy I did like four movies
with this one cat
this guy had a huge TV show in the 80s
and 90s 90s he was huge this guy he was
America's [__] sweetheart but then he
Twitter came and this [__]
opened up his mouth about his political
views and [__] and people throw so much
hate at this dude I did a movie with him
and the first movie I did with him was
he was very cool but I also noticed that
he played Four football games on the
training squad for an NFL [__] team
and they cut him he played four [__]
NFL games we're a trading Squad the four
Dudes that practice outside without a
[__] helmet and [__] they just
practice outside
but if you talk to this guy when he
talks to you he'll talk to you like he's
an NFL analyst he thinks he's [__]
Michael Irvin I mean it's it's it's
disgusting but that's what Hollywood
allows you you don't have to do
something for a long time and be the
master of it they'll take the thing you
did the smallest amount and they'll blow
it up like you were [__] some and in
his mind I mean he would come every
Sunday we'll be shooting and give his
picks the guy [__] couldn't pick a
winner the guy didn't know anything but
they blew it up like that now he's being
hated for political [__] and he's a nice
guy and he did some great things but he
was always one of those guys on the set
and [__] and one day I remember he got a
little kinky with me and I got kinky
back with him because that's what
happens to those people he had that
little edge of white privilege to him
and [__] and especially on the set
he pushed I pushed back and he [__]
lost it
he lost it guys and it was very
interesting to see because there was no
smile on my face I said well I said back
to him and I didn't care if I lost the
job I thought the movies didn't pay much
the movies were paying me a hundred
dollars a day I got a little back end of
the money cash after I Shot the movie
but I wasn't getting rich of these
things and nobody was watching these
movies I was just doing them to practice
my acting it was great to practice your
acting and look at his script and attack
it from a different situation Doug after
the second movie we basically never
talked again
and then after like the third movie he
stopped putting themselves in the movies
and he started producing
it was guys it was so [__] weird
and I remember that somebody said to me
hey man you know him well why don't you
reach out to him get him on the podcast
I'm like not
in a million years I don't want to put
that guy's [__] because if them lips
are moving that [__] lying
those guys they just tell you what you
want to hear and when you meet them you
meet him for 10 seconds and you're like
oh my God he was so nice hang out for
another day hang out for another day
with these [__] egos hang out for you
they're a bunch of [__] egos man and
you see what's going on now like I mean
and Bill Murray's people didn't even
answer back for [__] uh for comment
for nothing it's like
listen you could be a douchebag and that
shit's gonna come back and bite you in
the [__] ass people are sick and
tired of dealing with those type of
people
and you know it's like when a girl does
a TV show makes money does a movie and
then 10 years from now she puts out a
book and how she got molested and how
they treated on the thing why weren't
you complaining while it was happening
huh
oh because they were paying you and you
didn't want to lose your job so you let
somebody talk to you that way it's too
late for love lady you can't come at me
now and say oh this guy you know he paid
you all you were getting forty thousand
dollars an episode there's people in
this country that don't make forty
thousand dollars a [__] year
and I understand but why don't you open
your mouth then
you would have still kept your [__]
job you would look like a [__] hero
it makes me believe that you were having
a good [__] time doing it playing a
game sexually a little sexual [__]
stress on the set I've been on sets guys
and I've seen the little light sex
what's that [__] when they anxiety they
call it something like not innuendos but
very like uh
it's like it's like a little bit more
than flirting but a little less than
enough to smack you in the face like
they'll say different things I just say
it
that's why nobody ever [__] with me on
those sets because I just said it
I didn't [__] around with like well
maybe you could you know they all like
the cute actors they'll well maybe you
could you know do this and and the
[__] costume ladies then two weeks
later oh he tried to sexually harass you
yeah why because you sucked his dick
and then he didn't give you his number
you know I I said guys it's [__]
ridiculous but anyway it's [__]
Monday [__]
we got Monday night [__]
football tonight in DraftKings is there
you got [__] Denver against LA
tonight who's better than you nobody
I don't even know what the [__] just
happened I'm feeling a little better
today uh I was sick for the last two
weeks I had to go to Dr antibiotics the
whole [__] deal
but uh finally I started feeling a
little better I've been having bad
[__] headaches you know
covet was three four [__] days this
flu today makes it two weeks two weeks
and I still got green [__] coming out of
my nose I'm still spitting colors I got
a [__] headache all goddamn day so
just take care of yourself guys I don't
know if you got a flu shot or not I'm
not gonna tell you to get no [__] the
flu shot I haven't taken I've never
taken a [__] flu shot I was that the
national natural immunity orange juice a
little reefer you're good to go you know
what I'm saying
so yeah hopefully this week we will
[__] uh
figure out what the [__] is going on
tremendous weekend yesterday listen man
I don't I like every type of sport I
don't give a [__] and it's not even
about
gambling or putting a bet in for some
reason yet this year I I'm getting into
baseball
my daughter's into it I got into it and
uh
I watched I didn't watch it there's no
way I would sit through 18 [__]
Innings I'm not gonna lie to you I bet
Houston I had the money line because
it's a playoff everybody wins by one
I think I came home showered and I
watched two innings of it and it was
tied up 18 Innings I ended up winning 27
dollars
it's after five hours I was making like
two bucks a [__] an hour yesterday so
if you bet Houston yesterday that was a
long [__] day to win [__] 30 bucks
but I also had Cleveland in the playoffs
and then last night I was sitting with
my daughter and we're watching the
Dodger game the Dodgers were up it was
like the sixth inning I'm like ah
I see the [__] San Diego Padres
coming back I put
10 bucks on the odds of them coming back
and I saw it paid 78 dollars but we were
watching a Honeymooners Saturday night
and she fell asleep watching the Mumbo
episode I let her sleep and I watched a
little bit of the [__] when he gets
the victim episode and then I said Mercy
let's go upstairs [__] it so I forgot
the game was even on I woke up Sunday
morning I go to look at the football
lines I'm like oh [__] I won that 78
dollars for the ten dollars they came
back I thought I was gonna watch two
winnings of the [__] game but a
chains
this week I had to [__] do something
guys that I didn't want to talk about it
but let's talk about it how to do
something that I hate doing I [__]
hate doing this [__]
when I get mad at somebody
it takes me two days to recover
I don't get mad like normal people
I get
I got
a hot blood guys my blood boils quickly
and
you know when I get hot and I have to if
I get hot at you
and I don't say nothing to you I work it
out in my head then I'm okay
but if I get really hot I have to say
something to you
it [__] irks me it just irks me for
two days my blood pressure stays up I
can't really sleep
so I'm gonna tell you guys what happened
you tell me what you think
I took this as a personal attack maybe
you guys think and enjoy you overreacted
I enjoy the town I live in I enjoy it a
lot and I've been here for two years and
I've kept my mouth shut I haven't said a
[__] work
my daughter plays softball as you guys
know
listen I don't again I don't coach I
don't wear a Jersey
I don't know nothing about baseball
especially with girls so I sit I get my
chair and I sit down I take a few
Edibles I smoke some dope before I get
there and you don't hear dick on Uncle
Joey that's just how I roll I don't want
to say nothing okay every once in a
while I'll talk to one of the moms I the
dad's talk to me the whole thing
the girls are six and [__] up they
had a great [__] season
so this is travel ball
when you play travel ball you dedicate
they're your number one team
and they ask you please don't the rules
the number one rule is it's 100
commitment that if you play another team
that's on your decision you still got to
show up for those [__] games
again I don't know nothing
I get high I sit there I get some
vitamin D and I talk to parents and I
giggle
it's a lot better than being in the
[__] hotel room on a Saturday so
we were up six it was six oh it was this
Saturday that we had the show in City
Hall uh October 8th maybe it was it
October 8th and Lee was here so Lee and
I went to her first she got a double
header they started at three when we get
that as eight girls
no I don't I don't I didn't count them I
just heard the wives say there's eight
girls with one short who's short it was
a girl on team that's a great player
sweetheart of a girl and they said I
think she's sick
okay
I didn't think about it you know people
getting sick I'm sick coveted you know
you accept this [__]
uh
we went home I had to do the show I
didn't stay there and now something that
happened at the game some racism [__]
uh you know and again it's it's it's
it's [__] disgusting that it's in
with kids you know these aren't kids
like I was in Harlem saying [__] these
are kids nice [__] Suburbia down here
so a couple days later we find out that
the girl who was supposed to be sick
didn't show because her dad one of the
coaches on our team
put her in a different in a in a club
game like a club thing that you belong
to a baseball club I don't really know I
don't know the particulars and again I
don't get involved I just hear the mom
saying this is not good
this guy's not a regular dad he's a
coach on the team
and you know
so
I hear about it I get to the field on
Monday or Tuesday for practice and I see
that the guy's not there
his wife again who's the sweetheart with
the daughter
are there and I'm thinking to myself
that's weird I just heard that the guy
[__] took his daughter out and now
the guy's not here goes back to what I
always say guilty conscious is no
[__] accuser okay
as a matter of fact
she was sick on Saturday but now it's
Tuesday and she's the first one there
jumping up and down again I like the kid
the kid's a great player sweetheart of a
girl nice family he's always been like a
little [__] you know who bots so
that's the word on the street that he
[__] took it to a different club and
that she missed the playoff game
you know these are the girls that she's
been with for two [__] years they
went to a party so we couldn't figure it
out so Friday night we had to practice
and you know I got a couple mushrooms in
me
it's [__] Friday I got a couple
Edibles in me I had a great day Friday
I was feeling a little better I was
getting out of the house you know I had
struggled Friday
so
I go down to the uh
food practice I tell my wife I'll be
there in about 10 minutes go ahead I had
to share in my car and I drive to the
practice
no I get out of the [__] car and I
got whenever I do mushrooms the the gels
from Philly the the gummies [__]
tremendous from sillies I my breath
something happens to my breathing it
affects my breathing when I go on a long
walk for some reason I don't know why so
I get out of the car and I gotta walk
the field so I walk the [__] field
and as I make the turn who do I see now
the wet on the street was the daughter
couldn't play which I I could care less
if she plays or not it's you know but
she couldn't play because she didn't
play enough games
she had she missed a couple games for a
couple Innings who's on the field the
daughter and the dad is there they're
warming up
so I'm walking with my chair
and uh
I'm walking I see the moms I'm like hey
ladies what's happening the girls are
warming up and the dance dance and then
he's got a stupid look on his [__]
face
you know what it must have bothered me
that much because I went up to him like
oh listen cocksucka I gotta have a word
with you and you know I never really
spoke to this guy I just came out with a
[__] sucker out of them
and he goes well I'll put it in my
schedule and I [__] hung my chat down
I go hey man what happened last [__]
Saturday
how come your daughter wasn't here I
heard she was playing another game he's
like oh she she was sick and my son had
a game and stabbed him out I'm like bro
that's not what I [__] heard once he
said she was sick
he just lied to me
he just lied to me you know one of the
coaches from our team was talking to one
of his friends who coaches at that club
by mistake this is why you got to be
careful who the [__] you tell your [__]
to it's like me bumping into Mike after
I haven't seen him in a year and he's
like hey Mike where you been oh I'm
coaching this club down in Freehold
really I think one of my girls plays
with you boom and the guy goes yeah in
fact she played Saturday
so this guy is a [__] sweetheart of a
guy this coach that got this news he
didn't want to really throw him under
the bus I guess he told my wife and my
wife got it back to me and I just you
know guys listen
I am so sick and [__] tired
of everybody looking at their child and
seeing [__]
listen I want great things from my
daughter but that doesn't mean I'm gonna
lie for her
and that doesn't mean I'm gonna do kinky
[__] which at the end of the day ain't
gonna do nothing nothing for that child
you know I sit in all those baseball
games over the years last two years
and every [__] parent from the other
team our team you know and I got that
they eventually moved away but
they always uh it's always about how uh
you know what we spoke to a coach
in [__] Cuba he's gonna come up on
the weekend on a bicycle and Coach might
it's always like listen
my daughter never played softball before
when I took around that field for the
first time what'd you think I expected
you think I expect to beat [__] roast
she never played softball before she
never swung a bat before it's just lucky
she's got a little athletic blood in
there and she took to it she said and
she's not a great player my daughter
she's a lot better defensively than
offensively but you don't see me
calling Joe Rogan and going hey can you
get me a meeting with the Texas Rangers
I want to bring Mercy down there to
pitch and put pressure on this poor kid
my right now my daughter's playing the
[__] drums
she plays wreck ball she plays softball
and she goes to MMA and she's in fourth
grade with that killing her with
homework they're killing her with [__]
she's pretty good but they're still
killing her with [__] it's fourth grade
La wasn't teaching the [__] California
wasn't teaching his [__] we're busy here
we're busy I'm saying like we she got a
bunch of [__] going on so what do you
want me to do all those activities but I
noted the drum she plays the drum in the
band what do you think I called John
Bonham from the grave Adam come over and
teach my daughter lessons because I'm
Uncle Joey is that what you think I did
no
when she goes to MMA what do you think I
take her to [__] Enzo and say do
something with my daughter she's nine
she's nine what are you gonna do with my
daughter
I treat her do what the [__] you're
doing right now for fun
when I this days I go to Mercy I'm
taking you to [__] MMA and she'll go
I don't know I'm not feeling Mercy you
gotta go to MMA okay Dad
when we get to MMA she walks in the door
she's giggling within four minutes
giggling with her girls and the guy with
the big ears is a a cute kid he's
[__] huge or big ears they giggle
they throw kicks on each other I tell
them Mercy you see aren't you happy you
came yeah when I take it to the softball
field and somebody says something I go
shhh you hear that
that's kids laughing
that's kids laughing what what what do
you want do you want to put pressure on
her now let's take her to a fishing
clinic this is what you got to do 20
push-ups a day guess what by the time
she's 13 she's gonna hate that [__]
anyway and she's gonna hate me I've
never looked at Mercy as a [__]
living vicariously you know what
I had my own life I made my own mistakes
and I made my own adjustments and I came
through thank God I have my own life I'm
not sitting here going and there's a guy
oh my God
oh my God Mike I've been dying to tell
you this
there's a guy that I used to I knew his
wife
his wife was a comedy promoter
[__] great lady she just couldn't get
it together red band was tight with her
I was tight with her we tried to help
her but she was just one of those people
that you know
she was too soft as a comedy Booker
but then I found out
there was a reason she had the goofiest
husband ever
the goofiest husband ever and then I
found out through somebody that
this guy his mother invented like the
tire
like his grandfather this guy had like
20 million dollars in the bank he's a
trust fund guy he's got a stadium in his
backyard he's got a [__] Amphitheater
in his backyard they live up north you
know
she was doing good with comedy she was
trying to put the pieces together then
one day she got pregnant beautiful girl
I loved her I forget what her name is
and I've been gone from that scene I
haven't seen him probably six to seven
years but
I started seeing pictures of him
and
they had a boy [__] beautiful little
boy blonde curls the whole thing
but brother they already got them with
fake tattoos
you know heavy metal t-shirts snakes
pants like Jimmy Page
they got them playing the drums they got
and the kids talented as [__] you can
see that you know he's but it's like
just a little too creepy like they
already have more makeup on and at the
rainbow
oh and it's just a little too much you
could see that he's living his rock star
wannabe life through him but the guy had
so much money he never had a chance to
play the ukulele like Sting you know
saying he's just [__] did what he did
and I look at those things like that
like I appreciate you loving your child
and you [__]
turning them on to the drums you know
there's a drum in my living room right
now a snare drum she's up there like
with those people in the [__]
Declaration of 1776 they're playing like
that snare drum that's the band she's in
she's not a Led Zeppelin band
but I I think I showed a one drumming
thing we've checked out strumming but
it's not like I had John Bonham this is
what you have to look like Moby Dick no
I just showed her like some some guy
doing basic then they teach it it's
twice a week she goes you know I'm not
here to break her back I read the book
Pistol Pete Maravich I'm a big fan of
Pistol Pete I was a big fan of
everything Pistol Pete did but I wasn't
a fan of how he was raised his father
was I read like three books on Pistol
Pete and I appreciated the dad's bravado
and the push
but the dad was a nasty alcoholic he
would beat him he would make him sleep
outside
he would make him sleep on the [__]
in a tent in the winter if he didn't
score a certain amount of points that's
not for me guys that's never been for me
if you try that [__] on me I would run
away too you know and I have a living
thing that that happened to my brother
George is a sweetheart I love George
with all my heart his daughter was one
of the best [__] softball players in
Hudson County one of the best softball
players in the state but guess what
she did great in high school but she was
pushed so much it was such a push
that one day she just said enough I
don't want to play this no more
now she's trying to get back into
coaching and stuff we told her she'd
come down and Pitch with Mercy whatever
she's a great kid but I just want to let
my daughter do what the [__] she wants
to do
when she's 13. if she takes it I don't
want to play the drums no more Dad I
think I'm going to just want to play
softball and [__] MMA you know now
you narrow it down and you put more
effort into those activities you know
but I'm not gonna [__] press her to
do anything
right now she's just a little [__]
girl and let's get that even better
she's just a little kid and guess what
that's something I never was I never had
the fun she's having now without
breaking a window without you know
shooting a BB at a [__] bird without
throwing singles out the window I didn't
have the fun she has now
so it's very interesting to see so
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive it's Monday [__] I want to
thank you guys for supporting on a
beautiful Monday morning get your goals
and let's do this [__] Bill Murray's a
puke and we got a great week give Kanye
a break you know he's half robots
they're probably giving him [__] and
whatever the same vitamins they gave
[__] uh you know the the Olympic they
got he became a woman no yeah so give
Kanye a break he's even if you're Jewish
come on people been talking [__] about
us Jews for years who gives a [__] you
know what I'm saying stay black Uncle
Joey loves you and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you for sticking it out with
your Uncle Joey you guys know I've been
eating healthy for the last couple of
years or at least I try that's why I've
been taking beef organ and supplements
from heart and soil beef organs are the
most nutrient dense foods on the planet
listen ever since I've been doing these
for about three weeks what I do have to
notice is I'm a little stronger
I feel more recovery and I take the
whole package and the warrior
supplements people with organs for
thousands of years never suffered from
what we got today obesity heart disease
autoimmune issues or infertility because
they were eating organs founded by Dr
Paul saladino heart and soul supplements
are made from grass-fed finished beef
organs feel like a man when you take
this supplement made from liver heart
kidney spleen
and testicles heart and soil can help
you reclaim
the birthright the radical Health go to
Heart and Soul dot C Dash o That's heart
and soil dot C Dash o which is like go
use Joey 10 for 10 off your first order
that's heart and soul dot Co use code
Joey 10 or for applies to one-time
purchases not subscriptions the joint is
also brought to you by CBD lion the best
CBD on the market how do I know because
I've been living often for the last four
[__] years whether it's to rub for my
shoulders or my knees the kinesiology
tape CBD line will get you there so go
to cbdline.com read the third party lab
results
and let's get this party started before
the holidays so you could start the new
year feeling Tip Top Magoo speaking of
Tip Top Magoo UFC 280 is here Olivera
against that [__] lunatic they're
gonna battle it out to the death and UFC
DraftKings is partnering up for the UFC
to make you some [__] Guinness right
now new customers off the boat five
dollars on UFC 280 and get 203 bets when
your fighter wins everyone can boost
their weddings with DraftKings same game
parlays the more legs you add the more
Guinness you win I love Peter Yan on
[__] Saturday night now if you want
to boost your winnings place a UFC 280
same game parlay and listen don't stop
there I got the weekend lined up for you
we got San Diego against [__] Philly
we got Cleveland against [__] uh you
know Houston we got things are happening
people download the DraftKings sports
book app today right now Monday morning
she could get it on tonight's [__]
game with LA against Denver who's better
than you nobody download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app use promo code Joey and
throw down a Finn to get you 200 and
free bets that's code Joey Saturday
night DraftKings sports book minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details now download the
DraftKings fantasy app or the Sportsbook
app and go win some [__] the
money I want to thank DraftKings I want
to thank heart and soil doc Co and I
want to thank cbdline.com and thank all
you [__] for always having me
we will be back Thursday morning
I got a nice guest for you she's going
to talk about vaginal [__] so I'll see
you [__] Wednesday morning Tip
Top Magoo stay black
[Music]